Speaker 1: Let's go next to. I
hope I pronounce this correctly.
Is it okay? Oh, no, no, no, no. This person
is actually just listening. Sorry, sorry,
sorry. They don't want to be called on. That would
have been a very, very big mistake. Let's go next
to Pim. This from Chicago. Pim, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 6: So I had a question on health care,
too. Like, I recently broke a vertebrae in
my back, so I'm just dealing with all of the
bills from the hospital and doctors
and all these different places.
Speaker 1: I'm really sorry to
hear that. How did that happen?
Speaker 6: I don't know. I just bent over and like
I thought I pulled something in my back and but
so we went to the I ended up
being so painful I couldn't
get up or anything. Sorry to
call an ambulance. Anyways,
the doctor was like, you probably fell
within the last month or so. And then,
I don't know, bending over like, you know, maybe
had a hairline fracture moving over, just kind of
did the deal. But that's terrible. Yeah, it's
honestly it's I've broken other bones and it was
the most painful initially, but the recovery has
been the fastest out of all the. Okay, so broken.
Speaker 1: Well good.
Speaker 6: But yeah. So
anyways I'm just, you know, dealing with all of
the bills from everything and my dad is actually
was born in France and my both of my grandparents
still live there. And his main argument against
universal health care is that the care that his
parents receive in France is not really ideal.
He seems to think that I don't know, doctors
aren't paid as much there, so they're not as
motivated to provide quality care. So I'm just
curious if you have any ideas of how it could
maybe dispel that notion to him that, well.
Speaker 1: Listen, this is a very complicated
issue. You know, I, I can't say that
much about French doctors, but I know
British doctors and they are not paid
as much. That is absolutely true. Now,
whether a British doctor will provide inferior
care because an American doctor makes more money,
that also doesn't really make sense. I mean,
if you're British and you work in the UK and
these are the salaries, I don't know that the fact
that some doctor in New York City is getting more
money is going to make you provide inferior
care. That I'm not sure about. But I think
one of the things I would like to see the left
do. Is to acknowledge that many countries that
might have better systems than the ones that we
do. They don't necessarily have perfect systems.
And you have to imagine a triangle with three, you
know, like it's a triangle. It has three points
where there are these three elements, you've
got cost, quality and access, and every system
is trying to make a dot somewhere between those
three. If you go lower cost and higher access,
that puts downward pressure on quality, all else
being equal. If you have higher cost and higher
quality, then you're pulling away from everybody
having access and every system is basically trying
to find a point on that triangle. And the
French system is not perfect. I talked about
the German system before. We've talked about
the system in Singapore. There's no perfect
system. The point is, do we want to prioritize
quality? And in quality I include the time you
have to wait until you get treatment. Do
we want to prioritize quality and or cost
and or access? And many countries do better than
us on any of those three or even two of those.
And then when you say, Well, which countries do
better on all three, then it becomes a question of
for what part of the population. And I don't
know that, you know, I don't know enough about
the French system to say specifically, but
it is not a shock to me that no system is
perfect. We've known that for a long time.
Speaker 6: Do you have, like a system that
you think like a certain part
of the world that we should.
Speaker 3: Shoot for you. Just want
to be able to give him a game sample.
Speaker 1: The best thing. This is so. So
everybody loves to just say. Single payer.
Boom. That's it. It's over. I've seen very good
results with systems that are a combination of
nonprofit, potentially through employer, or
maybe not. Maybe it's just employer subsidized,
but it's nonprofit and federally administered with
the option to buy up or buy into a private system,
if you so please, with a safety net system where
if you just can't afford it, you also you get
care anyway, which some states in the United
States sort of have. And if I recall correctly,
I believe the German system is sort of like that.
But I'd have to re-up my scholarship on the issue.
I've read a bunch of books about it, but it's been
five years and so it may not be accurate to say
that it's the German system that I'm thinking of.
Speaker 6: Gotcha. Well, thank you so much, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Absolutely. Great to hear from you